[Music]
and ouch news oh damn it wow you guys
soul mates no I just wanted my own I
want my independence okay don't hide
anything
it sounded better when we were
harmonizing did submitted by fresh paved
roads okay that see it is the best an 11
year old boy had to have surgery to
remove 70 magnetic balls from his penis
what the 70 magnetic ball he was
stuffing that or 7d zebedee with he
stuffing him through his hole let's get
got a big-ass dick [ __ ] yeah but I'm
jealous cuz I can't even stop a single
one in oh you probably could
I bet sure this kid was like oh this
feels good oh this is good nothing feels
good going down your urethra you know
tweaks our own man there's a lot of
people and that sick [ __ ] in there
through your urethra you mean guys or
even girls because sometimes when you
wash your dick and this soap goes in
there a little bit hurts look at you
guys all never happens dude I am doing
that [ __ ] hurts a bit I don't know man
wait didn't you think he could pull it
out like all together baby maybe we'll
try to get a bigger magnet and then he's
gonna pull him out and fell dude that's
a freaky ass kid no no pedophile
he was like Isaac's big tonight no way
11 this kid's dumb I thought it was like
5 maybe it felt good for him what's up
what's the H word boy star lasts for six
years Tigers the same thing no based off
my upbringing 11 is cigarettes talking
to chicks learning from older homies how
to steal cars like there's actual fun
[ __ ] to do where you don't have to like
oh when do we help us to my elbow with a
penis yeah my wenis well become a wiener
like this is like five year old [ __ ] you
know a name like stuff you [ __ ] on or
date that's five really there's actual
cool [ __ ] you can do now like smoke
cigarettes smoked cigarettes graffiti
like that's like eleven year old stuff I
wasn't doing that anyway me what we do
project clip with Barbra Jean
like I don't know the female version of
that no I was climbing Barbie 11 yeah
that's normal I was a link remember 11
at all dude grade are you in 11th 6 6 6
is the 4 for me in my that's when you
start realizing like I think in 5th
grade you're like oh wait there's an
extra cool factor you can achieve now so
now kids they start like doing their
hair more because all of a sudden have
an image I'm a 4th grade and under like
kids smell like [ __ ] yeah it's [ __ ]
boogers hanging out like they don't give
a [ __ ] but then I remember in fifth
grade I remembered like oh wait I got to
be cool and in sixth grade you got to be
really cool and then almost when you're
like 11 or 12 it's like I got deal
laughs you know what's [ __ ] weird
like I can't remember what it's like to
be at that age so but you know the walk
that I do in South Pasadena there's like
high schools and junior High's there and
then you'll hear like these kids talk
and they talk it's like kind of
interesting listening to their
conversations like this girl there's
these two little girls they were just
like oh yes they're like okay I know why
Jimmy's treating me that way I don't
know remember the boy's name I know what
he's dreaming that way it's because I
was acting a little weird was acting
weird she goes no you're fine you know
like these two little girls are ya
talking about like their social
interactions with the blonde like what
the [ __ ] is this how we talked about
yeah that's a Kalev 'n when you're like
we talk about when you're like 10 or 11
you think you're way older than you
that's what it was that wasn't what that
conversation was you were being weird
you know what it is it's actually
because of this this and that I'm like
damn that you elevated this little girl
[ __ ] weirdo yeah that's what we all
felt like we all feel like your big-ass
grown ups already 91 teenagers am i Ross
doing kung-fu and so for every Halloween
I wanted to wear my kung-fu uniform you
know when I was like 10 or 11 ah she's
gay you don't want to wear your uniform
this year anymore Mike nah I'm too old
for that [ __ ] yeah and we dropped out
for school park over there okay i'ma
walk over here dan you must have hurt
your mom's feeling I know I never had
that face where I was embarrassed for my
parents I think my parents were
embarrassed at me and they would turn a
bus dropped me off way before me I know
dropped me off in the front they like
more embarrass my pants well you guys
don't have my parents
you know what this is this is very true
though so a good point I feel like a lot
of kids feel that way though when my
brother first told me like no dropped me
off here I was like oh give me a kiss he
was like after after school I will no
Isaac recently reached that age where he
doesn't hold my hand in public anymore
any office it's understanding that no
fat girl asked me he was like mommy um
can you stop calling me baby in public
and I'm like no I will not
you are my love I still calls you mommy
though yeah he doesn't call me Mommy he
calls you Tiffany mom mom hey Tiffany
have you love British culture stuff
because like Harry Potter and everything
pick on me Mom for like three years now
that's time also you want to hold on to
his baby news yeah I mean mommy no no I
said I he calls you mommy mommy yeah I
told them like okay fine I don't have to
hold your hand in public I get that but
I'm calling your ass baby forever
I don't know [ __ ] kid my kid's gonna
open mouth kiss me till he dies be one
of those daddy on the lips right now
that's like oh that's my baby to their
girlfriend ah are you gonna be cool with
this girlfriend no I'll be cool with it
cuz I've always been lucky and had
amazing soy guys I have never liked a
little near anything or lately never
gave me my place so I'll make sure to do
the same so what about when his
girlfriend calls him baby and you call
him baby she's not gonna call her baby
she'll come papi dude don't worry about
yeah
papí eyes easy and Isaac like my baby my
baby and then it'll be like they'll both
be like yeah and I'm like oh no wait
that big one big one little one
why do you call it take up your baby umm
I call him a lot of things no he's my
monkey dude my baby
yeah hmm are you jealous no I was
wondering if like we're gonna have that
situation where you say like are you
papa let me go up which no oh yeah papa
yeah okay see anything else just baby
boy was a pop always a thing or was
there was that ever baby with you guys
it was baby - no I was it was never babe
oh babe is kind of weird yeah I've never
called him babe yeah baby's the thing
[ __ ] Muriel did the other day she was
like washing the dishes of [ __ ] if she
goes David I was like don't you ever
[ __ ] call me Kate yeah you call me by
the [ __ ] original name which is in
Korean is Tuggy we're just like sweetie
why did he call it why should she call
you David I don't know if [ __ ]
blindsided me cuz I was like he's not
doing anything she's like she was David
I was like the [ __ ] that's how I feel
that means that she needs your attention
yeah I was like are you mad she goes not
you mad don't don't stop me yeah it
feels weird calling him part yeah don't
call me [ __ ] David what's wrong with
you dude I could only call him Bart when
I'm referring to him in a conversation
with someone else even if it's we're at
Costco and all my three aisles away it's
like my last resort yeah that's how I
feel when you guys call me Tiffany I'm
like whoa who's that
like I'm so used to hearing tip from
YouTube and then you guys call me tip I
like Tiffany though like I also I want
to call Joe Joseph but no one ever ops
to call me by my full name ever name is
has way too many syllables too long in
Spanish Hale okay what the hell what the
hell Baba
yeah my mom always calls me now all
right guys I haven't told you the story
yet pretty much said it all in the
headline this 11 year old boy from China
oh god how do we make it yeah he's so
bored
such a huge big fun not these specific
ones but they're saying that these balls
are like five millimeters oh they're
really small oh he's some 7d in there so
he had it probably felt really good
he's very nice right no that'd be
[ __ ] funny that's like if you get a
catheter in your dick I should [ __ ] oh
yeah it hurts so bad he probably had a
heavy-ass dick once it's filled up so he
was complaining of pain in his stomach
and that's why these parents took him to
the hospital and then that's when an
x-ray showed that he had all these balls
in his bladder and so they had to open
them up so Barris as a parent they're
like difficult let you know your kids
shove metal balls in his dick dude don't
even do the surgery they're open two to
three cases per year of boys between the
ages of 10 and 15 is there any items
inside 15 okay let me ask you guys this
is your mom and I was about to get in
that age 15 would you rather catch him
with 70 metal balls in his dick or him
smoking cigarettes cigarettes it's like
a normal kid like a [ __ ] normal
honestly smoke weed if you're gonna
smoke anything because cigarettes is
just I mean not when you're not when
you're under the age of 18 though like
we can [ __ ] up your brain a lot develops
for you I mean what's a smoked [ __ ] that
explains all over them it doesn't it
doesn't hinder like mental developmental
pearl you could you know that will [ __ ]
you up but at least like after seven
years a lot of weed [ __ ] up there are
so many good are you [ __ ] up the
English language just to let you know I
suppose no we [ __ ] up English you've
never smoked me oh yeah I have but not I
don't do it all the time that's not my
thing an enemy yeah yeah yeah it's
something I mean but hopefully there's
like another option other than like
sticking metal balls in your dick and
smoking sir I gotta tell tyke of this
now yeah that's such a weird thing that
to tell you kid at 10 is like a by the
way don't shove anything yeah you're
gonna get really curious it's gonna be a
fun little toy for you go ahead just
don't put anything in
I think your generalized no use tell you
don't put anything your nose and your
ears and your dick yeah you know like
why don't let of course don't do that
we're not sticking [ __ ] things up
there no like those the girls that you
know I've heard of Catholic schoolgirl
stories or they're like shoving carrots
and [ __ ]
but that's our sex and not leaving it oh
maybe it's all good we're near I don't
know maybe that's all good for him so
they said that because these were
magnetic and stuff it was kind of hard
for them to remove it well they did a
minimally invasive up why they just get
a big ass magnet shot out whole body
doesn't through his like oh no no I
would think that after they took out
about 50 balls the remaining ones formed
a line and they just took him out in one
go also it did work I was wondering
would even get those magnetic balls why
did they have online you could get 200
for under tempo why do you need it if
you want to try it like we could create
design I actually consider buying some
because I like seeing those video well
don't put them in your house anymore buy
bigger ones so they can't shove them in
there no yeah I like the ones that are
like this about this big and then you
can make like boxes and cubes and then
you see them like just creating [ __ ] I
like watching those videos on histogram
oh you're really entertaining but ya
know man that's pretty crazy they were
also mentioning that this 18 year old
he's he stuck a 40 centimeter headphone
wire into his penis one and and they're
trying to listen for our heart like a
dick beat or what he left it in there
for a year
whoa for a year he was too embarrassed
to tell his family you said that it was
so painful but he was just too
embarrassed and then there was this 13
year old that had to have um a 10
centimeter electric wire removed from
this penis dam and they found that wire
knotted in his bladder you see aren't
you guys kind of sad that you never
tried putting [ __ ] in their balls
because it from a doctor standpoint they
could prop this based off of the medical
injury you can talk to a loser or not
yeah you know I mean you were just
having sex like guys are [ __ ] loser
it's supposed to hurt though maybe I
like it yeah so they said that these are
five millimeter balls right diameter
they said that this boy's penis could
allow an object with up to seven to
eight millimeters to pass through oh you
got a big ol dick oh where does the big
hole you read through a hole just a big
hole
I'm assuming big hole imagine having a
little dick in a big hole
hi Bella suck so bad a chode ain't no
shame you know that come this comes out
like a cannonball just [ __ ] ground
[Music]